تتعرض دائما لسيل من القصف الروسي لا
يتوقف وذلك لسبب رئيسي بانها تبعد نحو
ثمانيه كيلومترات عن خط الجبهه حيث نشاهد
عمليا القصف الروسي الذي لم يتوقف خلال
الساعات الماضيه في محاوله من القوات
الروسيه للتقدم باتجاه هذه المدينه وفق
الاحداثيات الاخيره التي
اشارت على واقع هذه المنطقه على المستوى
الجغرافي التقدم الروسي يهدف الى مستويين
الاول تامين خط دفاعا كامل مقاطعه لوغانسك
من خلال عبور نهرين
يقطعان هذه المدينه هنا ومن بعد ذلك
التقدم باتجاه العمق الاوكراني تحديدا في
مقاطعه خاركير
النائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه كانت قد
تحدثت قبل ايام ووصفت الوضع هنا بانه وضع
صعب للغايه لان هذه المنطقه تشكل النقطه
الرئيسيه نقطه الارتكاز الرئيسيه للقوات
الروسيه التي تحاول التقدم على بعد ثمانيه
كيلو مترات تجري مواجهات كبيره القصف
الصاروخي الذي طال مختلف المقاطعات واجزاء
كبيره من اراضي اوكرانيا بالامس سواء
بصواريخ اسكندر او 300 او فنجان استهدف
ايضا هذه المنطقه والتي تحدث عنها تحديدا
عن احد المراكز الرئيسيه للتبرع بالدماء
ضمن هذا الخط الذي نشاهده في الافق تلك
المنطقه تتواجد فيها القوات الروسيه بحركه
التفافيه من القوات الروسيه المتمركزه على
طول هذه الجبهه بدا ضغطا من هنا في محاوله
للتقدم هدم الناحيه لاطباق فكي كما يشعل
القوات الاوكرانيه وايضا لتخفيف الضغط عن
مواقعها التي كانت القوات الاوكرانيه
تهاجمها في بخموت